أنا سوزي كراتشي مؤلفة
كتاب طبخ أطباق البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​، أحد أنواع
التغميسات المفضلة لدي المطلقة في الكتاب
هو غمس الأفوكادو من الحمضيات مع
الجوز والفيتا ، ورذاذ جيد من
زيت الزيتون البكر الممتاز ، إنه مشرق ورائع
، هذا صحيح ، هذا هو أفوكادو الخاص بي.
نغمس ما نبدأ به هو البرتقال الذي أقوم
بعمل الأفوكادو فيه أخيرًا حتى لا يكون لونه بنيًا ،
لذا سنذهب إلى برتقالتين من السرة
هنا وسأقوم فقط بقص
الجوانب
التي تسجلها بشكل أساسي
لتقسيم الجلد  الأمر قليلًا بهذه الطريقة ، من
السهل جدًا بالنسبة لك أن
تنخفض مثل ذلك وتقشر ،
شكرًا لك على
قدومك لمراقبة جودة [الموسيقى] ، كما تعلم ، لدينا حوالي
نصف كوب من البصل الأحمر
المفروم هنا صغير جدًا على الرغم من عدم إعجاب أحد
لشرائه على قطعة كبيرة من البصل ، ثم
سنضيف بعض الكزبرة ، نعم ، لقد
أخبرتك أنه جزء من نكهة
ولماذا لا نضيف بعض النعناع الطازج من
حديقتي ، أعلم أن لدي نبات النعناع بعد ذلك
سنذهب  أضف القليل من
جبن الفيتا وعندما يتعلق الأمر  فيتا أنا أحب
كتلة كريمة جيدة من جبنة الفيتا المعبأة
في محلول ملحي ، ودائمًا ما أقوم بتفتيت بنفسي
قليلاً من الجوز لبعض القرمشة
، والآن
بالنسبة للأفوكادو على عكس جواكامولي ،
فمن المفترض أن يكون لطيفًا ومكتنًا
وسيذهب هنا
قرصة  من ملح الكوشر
رشة من الفلفل الأسود
إذا كنت من عشاق التوابل قليلاً من
الفلفل الحار ،
أحد صانعي النكهات المفضلين لدي
، السماق وسنقوم بتزيينه بعصير الليمون
ونوع من مجرد تحريك الليمون
من الداخل.  سنذهب للحصول على
رذاذ جيد من بعض زيت الزيتون اليوناني البكر الممتاز
هذه اللحظة في الوقت المناسب ، يمكنك إعطاء
هذا الشيء إرمًا وإلقاء نظرة على هذا
الغطس الرائع الرائع من الأفوكادو المثالي
الرائع ، إنه غطسة جميلة خاصة إذا
كنت تستضيف حفلة وأنت  أريد
فقط سحب كل المحطات للتجمعات العائلية ،
هذا هو الغطس الذي أحضره
معي لأنه ممتع وممتع ،
إنه مختلف بعض الشيء وهو
لذيذ تمامًا
[موسيقى] ،
نعم